let's talk a little bit about saving and
investing so I would Define saving as
just any extra money you bring in in a
given amount of time
that you haven't spent yet so let's say
in a given month you bring in four
thousand dollars and you spend thirty
five hundred dollars in that month well
then you would have saved five hundred
dollars now that five hundred dollars
there's many different things you could
do with it you could just put it into a
bank account you could put into a
savings or a checking account or you
could even get a certificate of deposit
and those are all very very safe things
to do with your money assuming that
nothing horrible happens with the bank
and even if something horrible did
happen with the bank which isn't too
likely as long as it's less than two
hundred fifty thousand dollars per
account that money is pretty much you're
going to be able to access it at any
time but when you put it in when you put
your money into something that safe
you're not likely to get much of a
return you'll be lucky to get even one
or two percent or even to keep up with
inflation but it makes sense to do that
because you're gonna have your money
there it's guaranteed and all of us need
to keep some of our money in savings and
checking account because we're not we
might not we we might need to use that
money to pay a bill to do whatever in
the next few weeks or in the next few
months now investing is when you think
about all right I have this money which
for the most part I would have had to
have saved already and some of it I want
to invest in order to get a higher
return try to get four or five percent
you ten percent twenty percent I would
start getting very suspicious if you
think you can consistently get higher
than 10 or 20 percent of return even
higher than 10 percent you're probably
having to take on a reasonable amount of
risk to do that usually risk and return
are related if you could get high return
with low risk everyone would just pour
their money there so you should be a
little bit suspicious of that but what
does investing look like well the
riskier end of the spectrum it could be
hey I'm gonna buy some new startup stock
that is stock in a company that has
isn't making money but it's growing
super fast and look at how its stock is
moving up that's a little bit
speculative that would be high risk
potentially High return at the other end
of the spectrum you could buy government
or corporate bonds where you're
essentially lending money to the gov
government or to a corporation and there
you might get a lower a lower return
maybe you're getting four percent five
percent six percent which is a lot more
than you might be getting in in your
checking account and the risk there is
only if whoever you're lending it to
doesn't pay it back and obviously if
you're lending it to the government
there's a very high chance that they're
going to pay it back so that's how I
think about it saving just the money
that you're you're bringing in that
you're not spending you're saving that
and then some of that you could invest
it but when you start to invest you're
going for a higher return but you're
also taking on higher risk